20 men
puppy I thought
there are violent and disturbing images
in this game great oh
welcome to stay out of the house
you know puppet combo
those guys I played many of their games
they make good games all VHS style if
that could be even qualified as a game
oh retro style pretty much anyway this
one should be horrifying I'm not excited
about it because I know I'm gonna die
difficulty you might not make it out
alive the intended difficulty
sure I guess
take the night shift yeah I didn't even
know there was multiple levels to this
well let's see if I can do the night
shift at least I don't know
what time are you getting out six
and even read that text
want me to pick you up
ah yeah it's too far to walk no I'll get
a ride well any money mo oh there could
be murderers about yeah too far to walk
yeah as if I'll be conked out by then
what are you offered a beer for you
later you you offered have fun when you
you offered
you you offered
you offered me a ride fine where am I
why am I at a gas station this was
called stay out of the house
I thought anyway
hello Hi how are you cats just in time
hurry up and punch in oh I work here
yeah we've got a hot day tonight
you wish
come on I've got to go
huh is the phone fixed uh that's my
concern is the phone fixed no the
telephone company never came it's still
dead you shouldn't be making phone calls
at work anyways hey Rick with Alyssa
side work to do on your shift now I've
got to get out of here
what you got to get out of here yeah one
more thing I can't find the keys
anywhere the bathrooms are locked up so
go behind the dumpster I guess
lovely lovely hey I'm just trying to be
pragmatic you should try it sometime
we're going behind the dumpster or uh
being pragmatic because I I neither of
those appeal to me how do I punch in
who do I punch
mostly porno mags that's weird
how do I who do I punch
can't drink on the job you sure about
that oh
I'm bunching
time card punch clock
you've never worked a job where I had to
do that
okay I'll work here now one of those
things oh I can't read this good God I
can't
I actually can't read this okay oh
okay sorry the phone line not fixed your
have to bear with me until the phone guy
comes
don't worry do not expect
my
any I'm not expecting any emergencies
you you yeah you definitely expect those
when they come
greed you guys to do a better job
on side work during your shift I'm a
expecting this to be finished when
I come by in the afternoon sweep the
floors place to the well I ca I I can't
hold on I I literally can't I I wish I
could let's do this
this is okay I can I can do this
I I oh God it still has the aesthetic
and I can do it
I still can't read that
my eyes don't work place items that
weren't
picked back where they
belong clean the bathrooms okay
oh
you can't do this to me
well I was right all right whatever Rick
whatever Rick motor oil I don't know
where that goes where's motor oil go
motor oil
power drill Massacre
where does this go I don't even know
where it goes let's go outside or
something I can't leave the store
where's
one put motor oil
where did motor oil go
oh
in the fridge Maybe
I don't know
well this is not helpful at all motor
oil car accessories oh it does look like
that okay
all right a one Chips
I saw chips here cereals and whatnot
chips chips chips chips chips chips
chips shelf doesn't look like chips some
candy
chips that looks like chips
that's chips
isn't that chips
that's so chips
how's that not chips
oh
okay
whatever you say
and you go right there on the weird door
okay maybe a little gaming
oh no Jeff wake up don't worry I'll get
it
Factory one
oh
there's a customer coming
hello
how did Lee hey ho
[Music]
ah thanks
you're welcome
all right
ten dollars for that uh how far are you
going bud
oh
you're welcome
I did it
I'm the best oh I needed to sweep the
floors and eventually I need to find the
bathroom key probably
hello
I'm sweeping
oh my God really
it's like I'm just gonna treat this like
power wash simulator
[Music]
hey hi
who's that welcome come on in
nice van
where are you going
huh
that's weird
that that's weird
that was very weird or sweep the power
of
10 employees so it seems like there's
more people here
can I be done sweeping
how do I
how do I be done oh
oh more refrigerator door okay
back doors locked where is the bathroom
door
I thought I said there was a bathroom
extra stock
wasn't there supposed to be a bathroom
door
am I crazy I don't see a bathroom maybe
he said back room and I thought it was
bathroom
I don't like this
oh there's a customer hello
hi
how do you do
how are you hi
can I help you yeah
I just need some cigarettes
okay which brand
uh Banshee red with a
filters
okay Banshee red with filters thanks
oh hey can I use the bathroom uh I can't
open it
open good luck oh it must be a bathroom
that's like outside or something
yep uh you can go behind the dumpster
that's what I was told I was informed of
okay
well if I
could find the damn Keys maybe I would
be able to do something but
I don't think it was like behind any it
might have been in one of these back
areas I'm almost at back rooms but God
banished the thought oh nothing there
nothing special
anyone seen keys
um
oh maybe I get it if I actually play
this game well I didn't even think about
that
I got a key wow
oh wow
oh
huh lower levels hi again
what are you doing here
what are you doing
yay
you're gonna
get some gas
you you gas it bro
okay
la la la
[Music]
I love a mini game
well that's probably not good us I don't
know if that bodes well
thought I explored every part of this
maybe not
oh there's two levels
to the lower levels
I did say plural
okay
all right
attic
I feel like
I feel like maybe something should have
happened whoa
whoa
am I missing something I feel like I
shouldn't
feel like I shouldn't be spooked by a
game within a game
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no
no
[Music]
well
that's unfortunate
that's not what you want to see
no you don't oh no you don't okay
where's that red Keto
oh
what hey don't oh well this is a
terrible idea because I know this is a
dead end oh well I'm boned well problem
problem problem
whoa
oh
foreign
basement God damn it
oh hello hi who are you hello
oh
hello
hi
hello how are you
ah there's a customer coming yeah there
is there definitely is I
I no my coworker coat in the back
what
uh
oh
you okay bud
yo you all right you need some
assistance
just browsing
brows away
huh
hey what's up hey what's going on
you have a
gun knife
don't be my high score
hi
-dokey then
okay
okay well that was great
time to play more death game oh what was
that fair
oh what
was that oh no no
okay big blood
grape I hope this isn't a dead end
be extremely unfortunate oh okay I'm
fine
huh
sugar tunnel
what
I don't know what that means also I
don't know if I'm supposed to find the
key elsewhere and I'm just wasting my
time by playing this game
um I'll keep going
I don't remember the I I don't really
remember I don't think I ever finished
power drill
what
what did you just say to me
oh
what what
quacking at me
okay
lots of dead ends
very bad place to get lost in
okay
oh boy
oh boy oh
oh the gray things are vents I see I
just need to stay away from the vents
my god really oh that was a mistake oh
well I'm dead now why do I have a bad
feeling
why do I have a very bad feeling
that I'm missing something
why do I have a very extremely bad
feeling
oh am I gonna have to go through all
that again
I probably am
oh boy
what
did I die
oh what
oh well
that's fair
so if you click you go faster that's new
you can Sprint
interesting
doesn't help if I run smack into him but
hey
you saw something
oh I could not be worse
doesn't help if you're terrible at the
game doesn't help doesn't help at all
actually just makes you die faster I
think it is waiting for me to finish
this game
oh no
Killer's Lair this is not where I want
to be
[Music]
holy crap
that's oh you're just gonna be here this
is your home right I I get it now oh boy
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy almost there
oh so yes Escape what do you mean
oh my God oh my God I can't I can't I
couldn't possibly do this I'm not
equipped for this mentally oh my God I'm
not equipped for this mentally oh God
damn it
no noru
come on come on come on okay down and
then down and then across up up this way
okay making it making it I got one key
somehow
oh my God hurry hurry hurry hurry hurry
hurry
hurry hurry that was bad
okay up down let's see up down come on
come on
yeah I'm free
I'm free I almost went right back in
ah Freedom Megan has suffered emotional
shock she'll recover in a crisis center
you win
I did it oh is that all okay
well
good
why did I do that what's happening
oh
but you just said I couldn't leave
what
that's been saying I can't leave for so
long
oh
why
why oh
weren't these locked
how do I clean the bathroom
I'm done sweeping
I don't know how to clean these how long
have I been able to do that
oh wait a minute
wait a minute
who's in there
oh
what are you what are you doing what are
you doing what are you doing what's
happening
haunted door
like what
oh you're trying to kill oh
there's something trying to kill me
what what
okay yeah I don't know why it still got
me why did it still get me I knew it was
happening why did it still get me
finally awake huh what's up
sleeping most of the trip what trip what
trip what are you talking about
[Music]
sleep all you want I'm going to stop
soon for about this break
who are sheep and
God does not
CH and God does not want you to be
successful in the eyes
Trump said no I haven't
truck has worked too
long I'm going to pee I'll be back okay
cool
foreign
why can't I see good
did I forget my glasses
how long have I been I don't know
Brendan
Brandon
how is he not bow I don't know how is he
not back yet
Brandon
Brendan
Brett Brendan oh Brendan
Brendan oh well I'm not gonna look come
on just please okay uh hello
Brendan
sorry I don't mean to laugh I don't need
to laugh Brandon Brendan Brendan
suspended Brendan
Brendan
Brandon I'm a little confused I was just
working my
time job
and then now I'm
looking for Brendan
Brendan
suitcase
Brandon
[Music]
Brendan
at the beginning of this upcoming month
all work in production conducted at
Crawford Mill will cease to continue due
to the lack of business over the past
year the owners unfortunately cannot
afford to keep the mill open and running
therefore it will be condemned and sold
to the state where they will either
repurpose the building or demolish it
furthermore the owner of the
establishment has been diagnosed with
stomach cancer likely due to raid
ideation exposure
himself and his wife will be moving away
from Cedarville in hopes to find a
better Treatment Center closer to the
city he sends his deepest apologies to
the employees who've dedicated their
time and efforts towards the betterment
of the company you may gather all
belongings within the last week of
production otherwise they will be thrown
out as the building gets clean before
being condemned thank you all okay
what's causing the radiation
never never before when I play other war
games do I constantly just go I'm sorry
what uh
we mean radiation what do you what do
you mean power drill what do you mean
power drill to my frontal robe what do
you mean that what do you mean
roof perfect well hi puppy hi puppy
hi
hi puppy hi boy where did you come from
are you lost me too yeah me too I was at
a convenience store I don't know what
happened
what is a sound
that can't just be wind
follow me puppy I feel better already
I feel worse what is that is that a
defense post that better be a fence post
okay it's fence good good good good
great actually what is this this is
nonsense I can't even see it up are you
there good puppy hello
all right so I really don't know what
the hell happened you know I didn't
actually get anything done at the I oh
teddy bear it's child drop this up up
I don't want to say hopefully because
all of it's not good lost in broken
glasses yeah this is it
this is
a Troublesome path
that's purposeful
why would someone drop their luggage why
would someone
why would someone why would someone I
was using get over here oh it's derelict
okay
oh great Bobby you there
oh you were in the car come with me
puppy please tell me you're still fall
good
I don't like this at all
isn't the rule when you're in a maze you
always make left turns just keep making
left turns until you can't make left
turns you make left turns
nothing but left turns and you'll get
out of a maze eventually and you won't
get lost left
I can't left
oh
I made it
less turns never steered us wrong right
puppy
that's right that's right
that's right hello
to all members of the Cedarville
Assembly of God this letter is to
informal puppy where are you going all
persons of the Cedarville assembly God
unfortunately said in an upcoming change
to our standards curriculum a heavy
heart of family even though it turned
elsewhere
sanctuaries they found three further
from the Bible in our God and unevenly
thought in fact they are not following
the Bible
oh
a puppy are you just having fun in here
were you waiting for me to finish
reading I was worried that you were
going somewhere that I was going to get
you lost
but apparently not come on
[Applause]
[Music]
you found something hope you find
something
okay you stay there yeah that's a that's
a good place to stay you stay there
probably for the best taste the other
side of the fence nope it's not I can't
radiation
it's like radiation town
radiation bill
big radiation
did I not make it the right way out of
the maze did I forget some here was
there something important here
uh I do not wish to leave but I feel
there's a no choice and for kindness
understanding okay maybe if I go the
other way in the Maze that'll be better
for me somehow
what's that sound
hi puppy you stick close Poppy things
ain't so good around here
oh maybe there was just much more maze
than I thought there would be
oh there was much more maze than I
thought there would be okay
what's up
what what's up what what's up what's up
pup left good good you're learning yes
left good
what's uh what's on the ground here
why does the ground look different left
yes good puppy good very good
you'll make it out of here alive yet
oh
um
what is it Robin they must have left in
a hurry
still fresh they they're in such a hurry
they left their blood behind
can they get anywhere weird what
happened here
ah Joanne Mann
Joanne man
our mission our pastor our room
James F Bean
authentic server of God through
worshiping God is his in his God
goodness has called me to preach okay
um
well thanks pup for leading me here
that's cool
um
kinda
weird
but you just followed your nose and you
did as you were supposed to do which is
all lefts all the time then another left
maybe I shouldn't be sprinting through
here no no left
left
this isn't a left
oh
oh this is scarecrow well I'll go into
the weird ominous house with red windows
and flamingos
yeah
what's up what's wrong
you hear something what's wrong
hmm a house huh
uh-huh well there's this weird radiation
symbol
what what did you go in
dog
Bobby
what
puppy
oh God I shouldn't have gone in the
house
puppy
huh
I can't tell where that's coming from
that doesn't quite sound like the dog
you okay
oh
what happened
what oh
oh my God the strength of
20. men
puppy I thought
oh my God
oh oh
well and that's why you should stay out
of the house
what was the whole thing about the night
shift
that's it
that's it everything you stare at a
goddamn house period no exceptions
oh wait a minute
wait hold on hold on
hold on
wait a minute
and
we're live
I knew it my stomach what did he do to
me I don't know a bucket what is this
used for I'll give you a guess oh
hole
I'm bending it
oh
sure take chair
lamp made of flash I don't know how that
happens
okay well at least I have this I don't
know if I can hide there
um
it's turned off oh good this is
uncomfortable yes yes it is night shift
abductor strikes again
Mill Creek Oklahoma the gruesome
realization of the confidence of our
once trusted police force shines its
head once again after the six and what
it can now be considered an undeniably
connected series of kidnappings from
late night shops and 24-hour restaurants
across a large portion of Western
Oklahoma
as of last night 34 year old Deborah
kapitzky is the latest victim of the
notorious night shift abductor that has
had a considerable presence in
terrifying our communities over the last
four weeks though initially thought to
be unrelated disappearance of three
locations show video evidence of the
same abductor at multiple locations
between Custer County and its
surrounding areas
do not appear wrought be slowing what
these incidents do not appear
to be
I'm assuming that my eyes just went
super cross-eyed and not that
was in any way conventional
a bullet
good
thank you valid customer brand new lock
preset code which cannot be changed
four six two four six two
okay
four six two
oh
I just chair of a hole in it
four six two oh great
so if anybody finds a wow leather huh
okay that's horrifying
I'm uncomfortable
lightometer
I can tell that with my eyes
where am I am I in the clock what
happened
oh my my lamp right
wait
oh my God I
I was very confused
okay oh padlock
four
no come back
yay
crew driver that's like granny
but very much like a soundometer
how does this help me how does this help
me it's up to nine o'clock should I
remember that
I will now nine o'clock okay it's nine
somewhere
oh oh
emergency gas oops oh wait no wait no
wait no wait what did I do I didn't know
the button would actually do a thing
well it's probably fine
okay
so there's something to do with that
clock the alarm clock which is now lost
there it is
it said set alarm okay set alarm nine
oh it would draw attention I see
okay okay so I didn't mean to do the gas
thing that's strange
okay I don't know what that's for
well a good thing I have a screwdriver
okay
oh good oh good in the vents
the blood and rust colored vents that's
where I want to go I don't know anything
that's happening
I haven't a clue
I haven't got a clue of what I'm doing
where am I where am I now
where am I now
chapter one The Bare Necessities
what
what food water medical tools and
treatment
stay hydrated that's not helpful
how do I keep myself from being turned
into a rug save game
oh
and the game begins somehow
I don't know how but it did begin
okay
well that's nice I have a hidey hole
that I can save my game in that I
definitely will feel very safe in and
won't be surprised to see uh
I don't like that hole
oh
he's chopping something on the table
looks like it's littered with severed
body parts but that's just what it looks
like
that doesn't have to be what it is
what
what smaller bathrooms through
oh I don't want a solid drop just yet I
I don't want that
I don't want anything about that I want
to know
as much as I can oh God all right fine
frick it oh I can climb can I climb back
in no
God damn it that's awful I hate that
another bullet
might I be able to blast him to infinity
and beyond
I don't know if I want to unlock that
oh you can
oh
ah
takes a little bit of doing but you can
do it okay that's good to know
um
okay where is this then
oh this is not helpful
wait wait wait wait wait oh
I am okay yeah okay all right I thought
foreign
[Music]
I gotta get out except Granny likes to
scream
s oh I'm in a different spot
uh-huh is there gonna be a way out this
time
yeah no
oh boy
oh
okay let me just shimmy Sham this
without making too much noise
yep it up okay made it out of there well
that was awful
um but
now I'm uh totally cool to
go home what did I oh
oh how did I not notice that before
you know I just don't know
no running water what
what was that
[Music]
a hammer
that's nice and I can actually swing it
so that means it's
usable for something
locked need something to open it
okay so I've got a hammer
what do I do with a hammer
who's calling me at this hour
who would dare
go away
why
was there like a
what is the Red Mist
what is glowing over there
oh
what is that
I don't know what that is
something's going on
oh you're locked too it's too
complicated to pick I need a key okay
but I did get you please close would be
great
good enough I guess all right so I did
get some kind of a
please
oh you're just gonna
yeah you are whatever it don't it
whatever okay I had
I thought
I need something open I got a like a
hairpin didn't I didn't I get like a
hairpin
here we go
hammer
okay never mind there we don't go
no hammer
all right
I guess I gotta go downstairs
you have a robot
oh it's the camera
of course it is because I'm an e man
idiot
oh God oh God oh God I'll swing you take
this I'll I'll kick your ass uh yeah
okay that don't work on you um
[Applause]
my attempts at combat were unsuccessful
ah
[Music]
oh I see
um
I'm more than angry bro
I am gonna get out of here for sure
oh God where am I
oh God camera film camera pieces
whoa
whoa It's Made of boat what
oh god it's locked oh god oh wow wow wow
what in the hell how did you go
do glares that doesn't make any sense oh
no
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
whip
I did my best
and uh it wasn't good enough well that
was my first attempt to stay out of the
house oh I went through all of this plus
of mysterious part four but I did save
so that was uh that didn't go good for
me but that's okay because if you guys
want me to I'll try it again and this
time I'll stay out of the house maybe
the only way to win is to not play at
all so thank you everybody so much for
watching
um
don't go into any mysterious radiation
Laden houses
just as a suggestion thank you
I will see you in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
foreign